Malisha is with us in Maryland yeah
probably I can't get it to turn off so
my bad I hit the wrong one
all right Malisha is here in Maryland
I'm Alicia how are you good afternoon I
am great nice to talk with you days sure
how can I help my question is my son is
16 in the 10th grade hopefully going to
the 11th is it too late to invest in the
529 here in the state of Maryland well
you could but it's not gonna do much
okay so because here the point of the
529 is it grows tax-free your son is how
old again 16 he just turned 16 we got we
got two years all right and so you put
$10,000 in and it grows 10% it made
$1000 and the thousand dollars is not
taxable so this is a hundred and fifty
dollar discussion $200 discussion it's
not it's a it doesn't really it doesn't
really break the bank that you're taxed
for this two year period of time so you
can do it it won't hurt anything unless
he didn't use the money for education
and then you've gotten yourself set up
into a penalty but the the growth is not
going to be substantial so the tax
savings due to the 529 is not going to
be substantial does that make sense yeah
that makes sense
and I kind of figured it was too late
I'm too late to save money for college
it's just the 529 doesn't give you any
big tax benefit because it's - you're
not gonna have a lot of growth it's too
late to have a lot of growth oh yeah
yeah but it's not to like to throw a
bunch of money aside for college and get
the kid into school and get him into
something and get a Ford that you pay
cash for right well I have a back-up
plan and I don't make a lot of money I'm
45 I'm trying I'm trying to purchase my
first home and I only grows about 50 52
thousand a year and I do have debt so I
have money set aside for a home but I'm
hoping that I can apply for as many
grants as I can get involved some
city I have about 5,000 satisfied I have
just about 3,000 and my son savings
account that I put aside myself which
was very difficult but I did it and in
like a lot of other folks I do live
paycheck to paycheck but I'm okay there
is no that do you have about fourteen
thousand you don't need to buy a house
travel stop you don't need to buy a
house to get rid of that mmm-hmm I've
heard you say that yeah you knew I was
going to say it so let's get rid of the
debt let's get the emergency fund bill
let's get you on a tight budget so
you're not living paycheck to paycheck
to accomplish some of these goals we'll
look for extra income and begin to clear
your debts out of there and then we can
be in a position to maybe just some cash
out of the budget help him as he goes
along
okay now let's switch gears don't switch
gears and talk about him okay
he's your single mom yeah you make
$50,000 in Baltimore
he's going to qualify for a lot of
different kinds of scholarships even
some need-based stuff so he is now and
you are now in the get him some
scholarships business like I want you to
apply I want him to apply for a thousand
scholarships between now and the time he
graduates I'm not exaggerating one
thousand of them
he'll get turned down for most of them
he'll get a bunch of free money he also
needs to get his butt out there and get
a job and he's gonna be working the
whole time he's in school he also needs
to pick a school that he can afford
which is the cheapest school out there
cuz he's broke there's nothing wrong
with that is exactly what I did when I
went to school a lot of people did that
hold on I'm gonna send you Anthony
O'Neal's book to show you exactly how to
do this without any student loan debt as
a broke single mom it's called debt-free
degree I'll show you how to do it he
doesn't have to have debt he can go to
school